you know Instagram falls right into the  bucket of the forementioned snapchat it  is absolutely the number one platform  for attention right now video is not  native to Instagram and we see that in  data we see people over indexing and  Harding up pictures over videos but  doesn't take away from the fact that if  you're putting out a video on Instagram  and you have an audience whether it's 42  people are 422 people or 4222 people  forty two thousand two hundred and  twenty two people four hundred twenty  two thousand twenty two two two people  they will see it 60 70 80 percent of  those people will watch that video and  that is enormous ly valuable 15 second  restrictions forced creativity you gotta  say in 15 and that's a big factor as  well what I love about Instagram right  now is that Instagram is massively over  indexing between the 12 and 40 year old  demo Instagram is Facebook in 2017  everyone all of them  you